it's monday may the 10th what's
happening you bad [__]
it was a tremendous weekend but anyway
the joint is brought to you by
blue chew listen spring is in the air
you got to be ready when love comes your
way make sure you have the confidence
where it counts with blue chew blue chew
combats
all forms of ed the same active
ingredients
as viagra and cialis but at a fraction
of the cost
this isn't the horny goat weed [__] your
[__] friend uses
to say some [__] rhino toe
from bolivia that you buy at the liquor
store blue chew
is an online subscription service
prescription service
which allows no doctor visits no awkward
conversations
no [__] looking at some doctor in the
eye telling them your dick don't work
and no waiting online in the pharmacy
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com
you talk to one of their medical
providers and once you're approved you
receive your prescription
within days okay bluetooth tablets are
made
in the usa usa usa
usa and prepared and shipped directly
it's way
cheaper than going through a pharmacy so
now
blue chew has a special deal for you try
blue chew for free that's right joey
free
free on a monday morning who shows up
with something that's free
nobody uncle joey does try blue chew for
free
when you use promo code joey at checkout
you're just gonna pay
ready five dollars for shipping five
dollars for shipping
and i'm gonna give you a month of
[__] hot ons
that you're gonna be hitting people on
the head with that [__] stick of
death
that's blueshoot.com code joey
to receive your first month free and as
always
i want to thank bluechu for sponsoring
the show the joint
is also brought to you by
this is a good one here you're gonna
love this
zip recruiter let me tell you something
good help is hard to find
it's like trying to find a needle in the
haystack
yeah you can post your job online or at
the wall at the coffee shop or at the
laundromat
but then you got to sit there and hope
the right person walks by and if you
haven't noticed lately
nobody's really applying for jobs no
more everybody's living big off their
unemployment check
so stop dreaming and try ziprecruiter
for free
at ziprecruiter.com joey they do the
work for you one click
and your job gets sent to over a hundred
job sites
get qualified candidates fast in fact
zip recruit is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day 2.3 million
businesses have already used zip record
recruiter
large and small doesn't matter whether
you need a loan
i'll gotta mow your lawns paper for your
company
a supervisor or you need a guy to
be the the general manager of your plan
zip recruiter is there for you and right
now you can try
zip recruiter for free what are you
talking about joey free
free at ziprecruiter.com
showy again that ziprecruiter.com
joey try it for free just by going
to ziprecruiter.com joey
our smartest way to hire
well we might not be landing the candle
this morning because
the lighter went down but [__] it here
we go
candles are lit
yep and let's start this little podcast
up
this little blue chew envelope for you
kick this [__] mikey
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday may the 10th
it's a beautiful [__] day to be alive
well here in jersey
jersey is the only [__] place that
the weeks are beautiful
and the weekends is when it [__]
rains
wednesday it's 80 degrees people are out
jumping up and down you can't go
everybody's working but [__] saturday
and sunday cloudy as [__]
raining raining on mother's day but it
didn't matter it was a great [__]
weekend
you know mercy's [__] softball game
got rained out that means we got to make
it up some other time which is great
sunday i [__] finally busted out and
went to church
after [__] years of not going to
church as a family
my wife found the catholic church even
though she's whatever the [__] she is
and uh
we went and had a great [__] time and
a great mother's day so it was a great
weekend
the mystery i want to talk to you
[__] about today
is the seven days that i have not smoked
weed for that
is a [__] just miracle
okay because i'm not trying
you know when you're not trying to do
something and it happens you're like
what the [__] just happened last sunday
i did the album of the week for patreon
and that was the last time
i took two hits of a [__] number and
it was like it had been like
for the last three months i noticed that
i had been smoking
once a month and i noticed that i wasn't
smoking in the mornings no more for my
appetite i usually get high
about uh probably 45 minutes after i get
up
to eat something and i notice that
that's it i don't you know i'm not i'm
not hungry even if i get high
so i'm smoking this dirty [__]
percent weed that people are [__]
dying over and i'm not getting high i'm
not getting hungry i'm not doing nothing
i would walk into the gym
you know god knows if i wreak the reefer
so one day i said [__] it
i'm not gonna smoke before i'm not
hungry anyway and that's how it started
and i started
then i started not breaking the the
[__] church rule
you got to get high by two o'clock or go
[__] your mother so at least
i would get high by 115 140
12 50. i was doing that type of [__]
then i found myself
not getting high till four o'clock
that went on for about two or three
weeks like four o'clock i'm like [__] i
haven't smoked pot yeah like i've been
busy all day i'm running around i'm
doing this and this
and then i'm like wait a second if i get
high at four then i gotta go to her
kickboxing class or baseball practice
or softball practice or whatever the
[__] i do at night
wreaking a [__] reefer so i said [__]
it you know what i'll smoke when i get
back from everything
and she goes in the shower and then i
was going outside at night
and hitting the pipe once the weather
started churning i go let me go outside
and i was just smoking a pipe full
that's it so i went from
just doing one pipeful a day
to and i'll tell you what all right
so here we go we move here i have all
this [__] anxiety
you know like i've never had before and
this is
you know this is what what bothers me
about people that nobody knows you
better than you
like nobody knows you better than you
you know what you do when you're alone
you jerk off you you don't wipe your you
know you do you pick your nose
you eat your [__] toenails we all do
have [__] secrets
and we know what we can and what we
can't do and what we won't do
i mean some of us have that you know but
you're like you know what that thing
right there
i'm not gonna do that no more like i'm
not doing that anymore
i don't care what they pay me i don't
care what they don't pay me
i'm not doing that anymore then there's
things that you're like i have to do
that
you know everybody has a threshold you
know so
for me i i never listened
i wanted to get off the [__] drugs to
cocaine i wanted to always get off the
pills
i always wanted to get off the booze but
nowhere
nowhere in my manifesto did it say
anything
about me getting off weed and i'll tell
you why because i found that at an early
age
weed kept me together i don't know what
it hadn't it
i don't know half he is like no joey
you're just a junkie for weed no
we did something to me we did something
to me that
most people you know how today they put
kids on pills
they didn't put me on pills as a young
kid that would not even work in the
[__] 70s
i discovered nobody told me to smoke
weed nobody told me to do anything
i smoked weed and i said wait a second
this controls the [__] that i can't
control like
my mind you know it was just so
i don't know what it was it was a
fixer-upper that's what it was it helped
me
feel a lot better it helped me
self-medicate
as americans call it he's
self-medicating okay
is he bothering you is he jumping off
windows is he shooting people
let him self-medicate if that's what it
takes to smoke two little
pipe fulls but you know i was watching
this michael vick thing
a couple weeks ago on 30 30-30 and it
was after he got caught you know his
explanation of it
and i understood it i'm not here i
wasn't mad at michael vick or anything
like that
what i'm trying to say was his
explanation of it was
it was in this culture like it was a
part of
his culture you know being from virginia
the south
african-american you know in those rural
neighborhoods
those urban neighborhoods rural
neighborhoods those urban neighborhoods
that he was a part of that he was a
victim of it or whatever
and i understand it because i came
from a marijuana culture i really really
did come
from a marijuana culture you know my
idol
one of my favorite people in the world
smoked pot which was my godfather
and at an early age i was like whatever
they talk about smoking weed that it
makes you
put on a towel and jump out the window
and all this [__]
that's i don't see that with my
godfather
i see a guy that smokes it and goes to
the movie theaters
and he giggles and then we leave here
and he eats an extra [__]
cheeseburger on the way out
i don't see that as a [__] he's not
doing anything
criminally or nothing is wrong here so
as a young man i already had taken in
the effects of marijuana my mother
smoked marijuana but she
did it with drinking and god knows what
else so i didn't judge it on that i
didn't like my mom smoking pot
it was my godfather that i watched i
watched and i'm like
this isn't as bad as a drug as people
are [__] saying it is
you know in the 70s this is way before
the [__] egg
this is your mind on drugs and all this
[__]
way before that yeah this was like when
i was growing up
it was it was like uh you know it was
like this [__] thing that you had to
do behind
[__] closed doors in the 70s and
i had somebody in my life that did it
and i could see that
it didn't affect him he went to work he
was a good guy
he was good to me all it made him do was
[__] laugh different
giggle and like i said eat an extra
cheeseburger
and then you know i came from that
culture and then i got into the [__]
music culture
and the music culture you [__] get
high that's what you do you smoke
[__] weed panama gold
whatever red you know that's what we did
as [__] kids to smoke weed
and i could tell even in my cocaine days
in my 20s and all that
[__] there was a part of when i what do
you think when i was doing coke i was
smoking weed no i wasn't
it was two different eyes i wouldn't
even try to [__] i was drinking a red
bull with vodka i don't know what the
[__] you're doing
so it was the same train of [__]
thought like
when i did coke i did coke when i got i
got high when i woke up the next morning
and i was depressed
no whatever the [__] it takes from your
mind when you're sitting there going i'm
not gonna smoke coke again
or snork coke again i would smoke a
joint to pick kind of pick me up and
make me think and give me a little
clarity
and whatever so for me marijuana was
always a clarity drug
when i went to prison let me tell you
something if you want me to be honest
with you
i wasn't scared of going to prison at
all
if you were do you think i was worried
about those murders and gangs i wasn't
worried about anything
my biggest concern was not smoking weed
and not being able to sleep because for
years
i was sold on the idea that if i didn't
smoke weed i couldn't fall asleep at
night and dog
if i didn't have weed i could not fall
asleep at night so are you seeing what
i'm getting to
so here's the [__] deal so
i always smoked weed it took me about
10 days when i got to prison to
i you know i was telling i don't know on
the early podcast i think
one with bert and one with felicia
i said a joke that if you think people
talk if you think black people talk
in the movie theater go to prison
that makes i mean black people yell at
movie theaters african-americans
if you go to prison they talk all
[__] night
how did i know that because my first two
weeks in prison
i didn't sleep because i had no
marijuana
so i would just lay there on my ten
[__] bed all night
and hear jerome what's going on nothing
what's happening with you brother
nothing
i would you know it was constant all
night long they yelling from the third
floor down to the first floor
if i had weed i wouldn't have heard that
[__] so but i didn't have any weed
so that was the first uh whatever that i
had so as soon as i got to prison
you know one of the roughest things for
me was being in the halfway house
and not being able to smoke weed and
once the switch went off
and i said i realized that i tested
positive for touching the coke
and i realized i tested positive because
i was a junkie i couldn't stop
snorting once i did get it all in the
control in the halfway house
don't get me wrong i would roll a joint
i would roll the skinniest [__] joint
you could
imagine and i had a punching bag and i
had weights
i had like a regular you know uh
inclined bench
with cheap kmart little [__] thing i
think i paid 35 bucks a month rent for
the garage in boulder
and even when i was at bctc the halfway
house and even when i was on community
corrections
i found a way to go to that gym
i would light the joint and just go
and take one hit off it blow it and turn
the joint off
and then i would punch the [__] out of
that bag until i was covered in sweat
my shirt would have to be covered in
sweat for me to [__]
finish the workout but i swear to god
for nine months i pissed in a bottle
doing that exact
same thing twice a week i would smoke a
little bit
and i would keep my level just the same
so they could never
ever say well it raised or whatever
because they give you a couple extra
whatevers i don't i'm not going to say
milligrams
or centigrams because there's going to
be some smart guy
that's going to say joey you're wrong
it's this and i know it is
i don't know the exact wording of it but
when you take a
a piss test or a drug test and the
results come back
they give you a natural amount of thc to
have in your body
because maybe you weighed a poppy seed
bagel maybe
there's a lot of things that will give
you a negative read
for thc i don't want you [__]
in probation now
to go to your probation office i said
well uncle joey said
that if i eat [__] poppy seeds i test
positive and
listen i'm just telling you that there's
a bunch of little things i don't know
exactly what they were
i'm using poppy seeds because they were
one of the ones when i was in there
this is 87. god knows what
does it now but there were certain
things that gave you a positive for
opiates
and marijuana and one of them was those
[__] things so
you have to keep it under a limit and
that's exactly what i did for nine
months
i stayed in the halfway house i was like
the [__] star
pupil of the program because i had
turned it around
little did they know that i was still
smoking pot
only under a certain level i risked
going back
to prison for [__] four [__] years
for smoking pot because i cannot smoke
pot
that is a sad individual
that is something that's sad that i
would go to somebody who has a child
and say hey you can't smoke pot
but if you do they're gonna put you back
in prison
i found a way to smoke pot and not go
back to prison am i proud of it
no not at all but i'm just letting you
guys know that
it was wrong when you have a family you
cannot
do drugs and think that it just didn't
work that's why
i lost that family that was the big
difference between this family
and that family that's why i lost that
family because
i was still getting the [__] high when i
became a comedian
show me a comic that doesn't get high we
are broken people
we're broken be when you look at the
comic he's broken
i don't care whether you look at dave
chappelle i don't care whether you look
at
anthony jeselnik i don't care whether
you look at joey diaz
i don't care if you look at bill burr i
don't care if you look at [__]
cat williams something in our wiring
isn't right
either we didn't get enough attention as
children something
ain't right we saw something as a child
and i'm
hey listen i'm here to admit it who
knows what it is
who knows what makes you go up and talk
in front of people
and if you notice that every comic has a
crutch
whether it's drugs alcohol sexual
we all have something that is over the
[__] top that's because we're not
normal people
if you're a comic put that in your mind
and understand it
you know the great rudy sarzo once said
when it comes to musicians comics actors
it's a thin line with the mental health
disease
it's a very i know a lot of comics that
you know i have mental health problems
a lot of them a lot more than you may
think you know for example my side you
know
there's a lot of us that have mental
health problems
some of them i'm free to discuss their
mental health issues some of them
don't know they haven't you know i
didn't know i am we all think we're
[__]
stronger than debt we all walk around
thinking there's nothing wrong with us
and there's plenty wrong with us i
raised my hand
i'm number one with this you know but
for [__] a year
since the pandemic started i've been
crying anxiety to you guys
and i went on a [__] road with those
[__] little football vikings those
[__] things
and that was my answer to it but i knew
deep down inside i had to get to the
root
of this [__] problem i just couldn't
blame it on
the pandemic and fear something was not
right here
about my behavior something had led to
that
so little by little i started chopping
stuff
knowingly and not knowingly like i told
you guys last week my wife brought it to
my attention
the other day that she hadn't ordered
espresso since
october we were i was going through
i don't know how many [__] espressos
a day i talked about in the tom segura
podcast you know
for [__] the last three or four years
i was drinking
two four eight [__] espresso shots a
day averaging eight to nine espresso
shots a day well
last time i checked caffeine is a
[__] anxiety [__] thing
you know once you start you i put
hearing aids on when i did the soprano
movie
i noticed that ray liotta had hearing
aids and i asked him once i go
ray do you have those because you're
deaf
and he was starting to tell me i don't
even think i asked him that i think he
started to tell me about
like when he's in a room and
he hears like if i'm having a
conversation with
mike and i'm at a dinner table and two
other people
are having a conversation about [__]
football
i can't hear what mike is saying to me
because these other [__] people
and then to top it off not only do i not
hear those people
but i could hear the [__] dishwashers
in the back slamming the dishes
and i could hear the fork slamming
that's not natural so i went to the air
doctor and he gave me [__]
whatever the [__] you called it hearing
aids the hearing aids were great until
the pandemic came
then they would fly off my [__] ears
when i put the mask on half the time you
see me on the podcast
i'd have the hearing aids in you
couldn't even see them you won't even
see them
they're just a little thing you rest on
your ear but i noticed something
i noticed that right after the pandemic
started
i couldn't wear the earplugs and i
noticed that my hearing loss
had been less than what it was
like i if you don't think i could like
when i put the hearing aids on
i could still hear my i could just hear
different [__] things
instead of hearing what is in front of
me
when i took the hearing aids off not
only did i lose
that but i also lost my hearing
because putting the hearing aids in lets
your ears go to rest like they
like i don't really need to work anymore
we got somebody doing all the heavy
[__] lifting
so that's what happened to my ears
that's why i said once a pandemic came
and i took those things out because of
the mask i go [__] i'm not gonna wear
these no more
because they were actually taking away
from my [__] hearing
you know when i was doing those anxiety
pills guess what
they were adding to my anxiety because
when i didn't have a pill in me
the anxiety [__] grew once i started
breathing through them and meditating
and breathing and [__] doing downward
dog
i've been doing downward dog again even
though my [__] leg is [__] up
i can't believe i could do it but even
though i was starting to breathe and
stuff like that
little by little i started knocking
those pills off
instead of taking eight a day it went
down to seven
six five four three and then it went
down to nothing that's how you [__]
get off them
because if you drop those pills right
away you'll have a [__] stroke
i don't even know about this duff told
me when he was on the [__] church
and then i googled it and i was like
jesus christ you can't even do these
[__] footballs without dying
so everything i was doing the coffee the
pills
and as much as i [__] hate to say it
because you know how much of an advocate
i am
the reefer that early morning shot
kicked in with the espresso you know
i mean it's a [__] it's like a
natural accelerant
for anxiety so here i am crying to you
[__] that i can't breathe
my heart is [__] having palpitations
but what i'm not telling you is that
i'm [__] drinking 19 espressos a day
i'm smoking 85 [__] joints a day i'm
eating
you know how many edibles a day i can't
tell you
the [__] anxiety those edibles give
you on their own
i love abx edibles my man justin
at abx is one of the best guys in the
business i love abx editables
they give me dollar zero i talk about
abx i take abx pictures
i post them on all my social media sites
i'll tell you why i do that
because i feel they're a great [__]
product
i've eaten edibles that the next day i
wake up
and i'm [__] hungover let me tell you
something say what you want about aba
abx capsules the 200 milligrams
all the 100 [__] milligrams when i
[__] eat those things
i wake up the next morning i'm ready to
[__] kill a [__]
there's no air lag there's no hangover
there's no cloudy [__] mind i am
gonna tell you the truth about one thing
i'm not gonna lie to you guys when i
made the specialty video the michael
jackson video last sunday night
i cannot lie to you when i woke up the
next morning i did not know where i was
not only that i i did not make the gym
at 11 o'clock
i had to call the guy and tell him some
[__] lie
but i did go back to the gym at 6 30
that night
just to correct myself here and just to
come clean with you guys
that was a little overboard the other
night that was me
[__] just feeling my oats usually i
do the [__] pen
fusely i do just the [__] syringe
alone
i don't have the abx's in there not only
that i ate the abx's but when i came
down here
if you know anything about me i'd
probably put another abx in there
and then i ate a couple of my wife's
five milligrams camino edibles because
they have the cbn
and the cby in them in a high level and
i also have to reach out the cbd line
this week
because i ran out of my [__] cbd
melatonin combination i threw a couple
of those in there too so i don't want
you guys to
think that it was just the fso and the
[__]
and i always put a little tincture in
that [__] too
even though i'm not supposed to so
between you and i
guys sunday night the tea of deck was a
little under heavy-handed
i usually don't put the [__] abx
capsules in there
i just do the syringe one tea bag and
i'm tip top
magoo i was just showing off for you
[__] but
at least i got the balls enough to tell
you exactly what went down yeah the next
morning i woke up
and i just laid in bed when i went to
brush my teeth i looked at my eyes and
they were
[__] busted they were busted
i mean uh [__]
bloodshot blood things had busted i had
a vessel that busted in 78
79 i ate quaaludes one night got really
[__] up and the next day my eye woke
up
and my vessel had blasted and my eye had
turned blue like somebody had poked me
in the eye
when i was like 17 and nobody had poked
me in the eye that was me
that i ate the quaalude my blood
pressure must have gone up but let me
tell you something
[__] sunday night when i woke up
monday morning
and i didn't know it like i woke up and
you know i took my little piss and i
brushed my teeth
and i drank my coffee and it was like i
walked upstairs
i walked down here to do some [__] you
know i do my journaling in the morning
and i do a bunch of stuff when i went
back upstairs to bring the coffee cup
upstairs i was like
whoo i gotta sit down here for a second
uncle
uncle joey did some [__] damage last
night i was like
wow i'm [__] up i had to jump into the
[__] shower and everything early
i was like i gotta jump into a [__]
shower i just laid in the shower
it had to be for like 20 minutes and
just let the hot water hit me
i got out of that i'm like oh you know
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go for a
[__] because i was busy already
i had to jump right into the fire once i
don't go to the gym
i got a lot of [__] to do so i said [__]
it let me take 15 minutes and just take
a walk
and i just went up to a softball field
and walked around twice and i was like
i drank a bunch of water i peed a little
bit and i felt a lot better that was a
little over the [__] top last sunday
and i'm sorry about that
but every once in a while you got to see
the devil you know what i'm saying you
got to have some a good time but anyway
going back to the [__] reefer
so all these things i had that would
give me [__] anxiety
you know i was getting them out of my
system but there was still one more key
in this
and that was the reefer now i gotta be
honest with you guys
when i smoke reefer i like to feel my
heart beat
you know i'm not [__] around here
like i'm i don't do pills i don't
[__] do
um you know vapors i don't [__] have
the blow torch and do the
whatever the [__] you call it i like
reefer
i put all my faith into smoking reefer
when i sit down
reefer to me is a [__] event
i want to get high i want to [__]
drool
i want to be able to eat some ice cream
you know what i'm saying like
you know you wanna like i had a dream
about eating m
m's last night i don't i don't [__]
know what i had
why i would have a dream about eating m
m's i don't even like whenever i've cut
down on sugar so much that i'm probably
having dreams
about eve eating [__] m m's but
you know it's like i i never
intended on getting the reefer out but
that's why i didn't even do the 420 show
i was like if i do the 420 show i'm
gonna have to do in the daytime
and that means i'm gonna have to pop
those edibles in the [__] daytime
and that means i'm gonna have to smoke
25 joints in the daytime
and i can't lie to people i can't do
that no more
why would i want to charge you 10 bucks
and sit there and take two hits off a
joint
and tell you i'm having a good time i'm
not having a good time
so the plan is this last sunday when we
did the album of the week
we i took two hits nothing happened it
was that caramel apple
[__] from [__] ice cream shop those
[__] joints are great
anybody i smoked one of those with said
that [__] is [__] great i took two
hits
nothing happened when mike left i
realized my throat was bothering me a
little bit and i go you know what
because that's what was really happening
every time i'd smoke
my lungs would hurt and i go [__] i got
coveted
now i got to go to the hospital because
i kept thinking that i had covered every
time i [__] smoked
so i'm like you know what i'm not going
through this i'm going to cup my smoke
intake
because every time i go somewhere and i
get an email that i thought i had
covered
i would go now i can't [__] smoke
because it'll go into my [__] lungs
so i thought about dave chappelle and
him getting covered i go wait a second
if he [__] got covered and he smokes
as much as he does
i should worry about this [__] but then
when he didn't get it like all right
maybe i'm over [__] reacting which i
was so i at least let my
self smoke a little bit but it was still
[__] bothering me like
i just was like i am smoking 32
to 35 reefer
and i am not getting high let's be
honest this is not normal
and this is not good what's next 38
percent reefer what am i looking for
forty percent refi
so i said [__] it let me just put the
brakes on it so here's the new [__]
plan are you ready guys
the new plan is plain and [__] simple
we take a little time off from reefer we
get our head together
you're gonna notice in about two weeks
you're gonna go joey your eyes are
starting to look
a little younger let me tell you
something my ex-wife used to hate when i
got high because you go
she used to tell me when you get high
you look 10 years [__] old
let's give it a couple days we're going
to see how my [__] eyes look
you know i could sit here i i was
telling mike before this
it's been five days six days seven days
i could sit here
and i love to tell you oh my god i feel
so much better
i'm thinking quicker and i don't feel
different
i would love to tell you a lie to you
and say you know my energy is 80 percent
up you know i got up and sang fiddler on
the roof
no that that i don't feel no [__]
different after seven days but
i did read that chart years ago there
was a chart
i read online
and it breaks down exactly what happens
to you when you quit smoking cigarettes
really interesting thing i saw so
like an hour after you smoke cigarettes
what happens to your blood
eight hours after you finish smoking a
cigarette what happens to
to you 24 hours after you don't smoke a
cigarette 72
hours after you don't smoke a cigarette
you know a week after you don't smoke a
cigarette
and the list grows it was crazy
how many things changed
in you know one hour eight hours 24
hours
you know it was like your blood uh the
vowels in your heart
shrink a little bit you know your blood
pressure goes down
your cl it was just the benefits of not
getting high of not smoking cigarettes
for 30 days would just you look at it
and you go
okay this is something i'm interested in
doing you know what i'm saying
i haven't seen a chart for the benefits
of not smoking pot
all i know is in the past when i didn't
smoke pot
i'd be very irritable um this is when i
was a [__]
kid though you know i was 27 28
30. if i didn't have pot i was irritable
your mother sucked dicks
you know i [__] hated life i hated
myself
i was ugly i was stupid you know
and i gotta be honest with you i have
not experienced any
irrational behavior any anger moods
any swings so between you and i guys i
think this is something that my body
needed
you know i i called a few of my friends
you know unlike america or they go to
therapy i don't know
i just call my friends i call the people
that know me the best
and i think the best answer i got was
from my man dean delray
he goes did you ever consider that maybe
your body doesn't need it because
you don't have the stress you had in l.a
and i go but wait a second
i didn't feel this [__] stretch that
you guys are talking about
so if i didn't feel the stress
how can i you know but i guess that's
what's it you know
maybe your body doesn't need it anymore
you guys see the [__] tea i make to
go to sleep
that's what i need to go to sleep to
stay asleep
so here's the [__] plan the plan is
this
the plan is to stay off the [__]
reefer
what's a date joey i don't
[__] know i'll let you know firsthand
if you give that much a [__] about me
i'll give it some breathe and then i'm
gonna flip the script
the t goes away the tincture
goes away the edibles go away at night
and i just take two hits off a joint to
fall asleep
like this whole thing started
you follow me this whole thing started
with me narrowing it down i couldn't
fall asleep
unless i had weed now i smoke weed at 11
o'clock at night if you don't think it
gets me high at eight in the morning
what do you think it does eleven o'clock
at night just gives me bad breath
doesn't do anything else just
now i got that reefer you have a ski you
ever get hit with a batch a bad brief of
breath
it's the worst breath in the world now i
gotta [__] go upstairs
put my sleep apnea on mask on and
breathe this [__] disgusting [__]
uh you know reef of breath you know so
that's done now what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna give it some time
i'm going to smoke again i want to smoke
you remember smoking and passing out
remember when you first started smoking
pot you would tell people
i can't smoke in the daytime because it
makes me want to fall asleep
ah that's exactly what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna switch it around so i don't
have to get high in the daytime
so at night i just take two hits off a
pipe
at 10 30 maybe two hits off a fat
[__] joint
and it's snappy noodle time via [__]
reefer and we're back to square one life
is a circle
and we bring it right back to where we
started from and i give my liver a break
my kid needs a break my blood stream
will break
everybody takes a breather everything in
moderation that's what life is about
you know it was me you know i'm looking
at things now i'm looking at friends of
mine
i'm looking at friends of mine that buy
weed
and i see and i don't judge them
i go there before the grace of god go i
you know they buy an ounce a month
that's a quarter ounce a week
that's about
nine joints a [__] week that's a
joint a day
in my world good luck
that's i was i was tripling that
you got to remember before i left la i
was going to the ice cream shop
formerly urban trees and i was getting
3 8. of 30 stuff
and going through in a day and a half
that's that's i would love to tell you
that
that's great joey but it's really not
good for you
to have all that smoke in you and all
that it's not good for you
i'm not crying i had a great time
[__] doing it
i'm not one of those guys that it's an
aaa meeting and i
had a great time doing it i still enjoy
it you don't think i [__] get high at
night
when i do those edibles before i go
upstairs i'm high for 30 minutes down
here
loving it feeling the warmth of [__]
the warmth of god's love
loving it i [__] love it it has
nothing to do with that
this has something to do with just
trying to get better
it's all a part of my [__] program
here you know i don't want to do [__]
stand-up right now
i would love to i would love to tell you
i'm going out tonight and i'll meet you
there and blah blah blah but
i don't want to [__] do it you know
we change in this life
we change and then you have to look at
it and go me
i'm going to revisit stand up in august
i know right now i don't want to do it
and i'm not going to bang my head off
it's just going to affect my mental
health
and my relationships and the fun i'm
having i'm having a great time playing
the [__] guitar am i jimmy page yet
no not really i'll let you know when
which will probably be never but i'm
playing a lot clearer
i'm keeping my thumb behind the [__]
neck i could hear
all six [__] chords now you know
my brain stew is a lot better than what
it was
three [__] weeks ago you know what
i'm saying so
i'm just gonna keep pushing uh nobody's
quitting weed
it's no reason for you [__] to
sit there and go joey's a [__]
punk-ass [__]
he's not smoking weed no nobody quit i'm
just taking a breather
trust me i had more concerns than you
had you know one of the biggest concerns
i had when i quit cocaine was
i'm not going to be funny anymore
do you know that for three years i
snorted coke for three years
over the time i really wanted to because
i always felt i would lose that
buck wildness i always felt i would lose
that thing that pryor had
the i don't care but what did we find
out that after i smoked
i stopped snorting coke i became a way
better stand up than i was before i
snorted coke
if you think i thought that before i
[__] got into
quitting coke you got another thing
coming my biggest fear would quit
with quitting cocaine wasn't quitting
cocaine
it was that wouldn't be funny anymore
well we both found that
out that was a lie in fact i got funnier
ten times funnier and i got more
specific and i started being more
colorful on stage
so you never know what might happen with
this towards the end
i gotta be honest with you guys when i
was doing stand-up i was taking it so
seriously
i was sick of bombing whenever i did
edibles i didn't i
i felt that i wouldn't have control over
the audience
so the last year i wasn't even [__]
eating edibles before i went on stage i
would take a couple hits off a joint to
somewhere in my [__] pathetic junkie
mind
it would let me feel that and that's
what it is
i kept smoking this whole time because
of my junky pathetic mind
it lets me feel that i am
it is working it wasn't working it
wasn't getting me high
i was just wasting two [__] hits of
great joints
and to top it off it's a 35 percent
[__] joint
why are you smoking a whole joint it's
supposed to be two-head [__] weed
joey and you're smoking a [__] joint
so all these things
didn't add up and this is what led me to
taking a breather from the [__]
reefer
and this is it
i can't wait to come back on here and
smoke a [__] joint and
for you guys to see the change in my
face and my eyes and go all right
we see it now joey it [__] works now
thank god you're getting high again so
we'll get and then when i go back i'm
not going to go back to 35.
i'm gonna start with jersey weed i'm
gonna take it all the way back to 14
percent
wait think i'm [__] [__] that's
what you do you go all the way back to
the lowest end
and you start smoking that [__] and once
you start getting high on that
eureka eureka
you have gotten to where you want to go
because now you're getting high on
shitty weed again
and you're sitting there going joy why
would you want to get high and shitty
wheat again
to start all over again so i could smoke
till i'm [__] 80
and be [__] happy are you with me
[__]
this is the monday morning joint but
there's something i gotta talk to you
[__] about
wednesday may the 12th i'm releasing a
hundred
nfts it's electronic art
it's cryptocurrency type stuff i'm only
releasing it
on patreon to the upper tier because i
own
i owe the upper tier
a gift for signing up for six months so
what i'm gonna do is
my wife is getting the coffee cups
together now
we're gonna put the car the joint coffee
cups
online to sell but the upper tier
of the patreon i'm gonna send them the
cups
as a gift what i have to do also because
i stiffed them in january
is what i'm gonna do well i sent you the
shirts early i sent you the shirts
so you would have them for christmas
there's not gonna be shirts this time
we're not doing business with that
company no more
management company no more so what we're
gonna do is
we're gonna send out mugs for you guys
having my back
on patreon from the beginning
with this thing and for helping our
people helping our comics that we're
down
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna release a
hundred nfts
they're gonna be electronically
autographed i don't wanna hear no [__]
that you wanna send them or whatever
they don't even come like that
they're electronically autographed with
a number number one to
zero i don't know what time i will put
them up on patreon
on wednesday it doesn't
this is just for the top tier people
so restrictions apply we're like [__]
uh we're like draftkings now
restrictions apply
you can't join now to get it you could
join now if you want
but there's still there's 400 people
in that upper tier and there's only 400
and there's only 100 nft prints
available
so i don't want out to lie to you and
say
run to patreon right now and sign up
because you're going to get it because
you're not i don't want i don't want to
lie to anybody it's not my
best interest i am coming out with a
30th anniversary
nft of comedy on july 16th
or about that date then i
by that time it will be incorporated
in the patreon payment i will have it
for the upper tier people and i will
make
more cards pertaining to how many people
are on that
tier so i'm not being a scumbag to
anybody
this is to the people who joined patreon
from the beginning
and had everybody's back in the
beginning of the [__] pandemic
this is the least i could do for you you
are
getting a mug as a gift
once they come in you know we used to
make the mugs in china obviously you
know what happened
the end of wuhan they don't want to make
cups no more
so now we're [__] we had a fine of an
american distributor
in fact i want everything american i was
sick and tired of
so we just want everything american you
know what i'm saying i don't care if i
pay more i don't care if
i gotta order from a company in ohio
everything went american because it's
just not worth it you guys are seeing
what's going on
plants are closing all over the country
car plants
because there's not enough chips coming
out of taiwan you know it's just this is
just a [__] nightmare a lot of people
don't know about this [__]
that people are on backwater you know
right now if you go to order a pool
in new jersey they're going to pay to
call them back in 2025.
can't even order a [__] swimming pool
in new jersey like right now they're so
[__] swamped
so everything is months behind you know
covid
china whatever yugoslavia i don't know
i'm not throwing everybody under the bus
i'm just saying that kovitz said
everything back
you can't even get a certain brick now
or certain ovens or
you know we established that we we
bumped into it
early on with the [__] joint that we
couldn't get the cameras we wanted
and the microphones we wanted so it's a
[__] up world
so what i'm saying is thank you for
listening to the joint
on a monday morning thank you for
letting your uncle joey enter your life
on a monday morning
and thank you for understanding why the
breeder from the reefer
it's not a breather from the reefer it's
just a little break
we're making a comeback and when i make
the comeback we'll make a decent
announcement so we all get high together
who's better than you guys i love you
[__] it's may 10th already we
did it
hope you had a great weekend it's gonna
be a great [__] week
i love you [__] with all my heart
now
for a [__] word for responses
have a great week [__]
see you wednesday on uncle joey's joint
let's do this [__]
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you again for listening to
the joint on a monday morning we did it
seven days without weed i can't even
believe it myself what are you gonna do
things are bad all over but anyway
the joint is brought to you by zip
recruiter listen good help is hard to
find
it's like trying to find a needle in a
haystack sure you could post your job
online on a cork board
at the laundromat or the coffee shop
then you got to sit there and wait to
see who
if the right person shows up and sees it
listen stop dreaming
stop dreaming and try zip recruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com
joey you know why because they do the
work for you
one click and your job gets sent over
100 job sites
and here's where it gets freaky their
matching technology hooks you up
with the people with the skills and
experience that you need
you're going to get qualif qualified
candidates
fast today let them play matchmakers so
you have
you don't have to read through
applications and sit there
and you know read all the [__] and
you know i went to the college of
no you didn't in fact zip recruit is so
effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day regardless
of the size of their business listen 2.3
million businesses have already used
ziprecruiter what are you waiting for
whether you have a small landscaping
business or you have a big painting
company
zip recruit is here for you right now
today you can try ziprecruiter for free
what are you talking about
free at ziprecruiter.com
joey that's ziprecruiter.com
joey zip recruiter is the smartest way
to hire
but it all starts by you going to
ziprecruiter.com
slash joey okay
the joint is also brought to you by
one of my favorites in the air one of my
favorites
blue chew listen summer's in the air
bikinis are out you want to be ready
when love comes your way
you want to make sure you have the
confidence where it counts
you want to show up with a big hard dick
so they remember you listen most [__]
momos show up with a dozen roses
roses die after three days the memory of
your big dick with blue
[__] veins sticking out of it is a
memory that will stay with them forever
it's like their personal own nft
nft whatever the [__] with a big dick on
it all right
blue chew combats all forms of vd it's
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cyalis at the fraction of a course
bluetooth brings you the first
chewable dick pill this ain't no [__]
[__] that your friend uses from the
[__] liquor store
this is science blue chew is an online
prescription service
you got no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations
and no waiting online in the pharmacy
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com
you talk to one of their licensed
medical providers and voila
once you're approved you receive
prescription within days
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package
the mailman don't know it don't have a
big black dick on it nothing like that
it's just a little blue in your pocket
you're always ready to get down you saw
the packages it comes in you slip it
right in your pocket before you date
even if you don't have bd you want to
show up with the best [__] missile
between your legs that you can
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and that's what you're representing
the big dick that is the usa and they're
prepared and shipped directly
and it's way cheaper than going through
the pharmacy so
they got a special deal for you today on
a monday
go with blue chew for free joey free
free use promo code joey at check out
and just pay
five hours for shipping that's
bluechew.com
use promo code joey to receive your
first month for free
and as always i want to thank bluechu
for sponsoring the joint i want to thank
bluechu
i want to thank zip recruiter but most
importantly i want to thank you guys
for being [__] savages and always
having my back we'll be back wednesday
tip top magoo with the joint i love you
[__]
have a great week i want to thank zip
recruiter and bluetooth
and you guys for always having my
[__] back
stay black we'll be back wednesday
ready to [__] rock i love you guys
have a great week
there you go
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
you